Hello everyone,
welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today's topic is Moroccan Daddy Joe
Morocco's,
Arabic dialect,
or is it Moroccan deadshot is normally
considered to belong to the Maghrebi
Arabic dialect group,
which includes not only Moroccan Arabic
but also Algerian Tunisian and how
Arabic Moroccan dead Asia is also known
as the Arabic dialect,
which is the most difficult for speakers
of other dialects to understand and the
further you travel east away from
Morocco,
the more difficult it becomes.
Some Arabic speakers say that hearing
Moroccan dead Asia is like hearing a
different language and some Moroccans
insists that debt Asia is actually a
different language because it's
influenced by the Amazon language.
Still other Moroccans insists that debt
Asia is indeed Arabic and is closely
connected with classical Arabic.
In the seventh century CE,
the Islamic conquest of the Maghreb
region brought both Islam and the Arabic
language to Morocco,
but before that Morocco is population
consisted mostly of people.
The term Berber actually.